a escasos metros de donde nos
encontramos en el norte de bogotá la
capital de colombia ha habido una
reunión privada entre el presidente
electo de colombia gustavo petro y el
líder de la oposición de izquierda
francesa jean-luc mélenchon que ha
venido a una gira latinoamericana en una
primera parada en méxico donde se reunió
con andrés manuel lópez obrador después
continuó por honduras con xiomara castró
la presidenta y ha terminado aquí en
colombia dice que ha venido para
aprender sin ninguna intención de dar
ninguna lección ya que piensa que la
izquierda en europa está totalmente
destruida y es latinoamericana la que
puede inspirar claramente es gustavo
petro el más adelantado en el
pensamiento es decir la reformulación
del marco de izquierda dentro del marco
del desafío del cambio climático
como una fuente de innovación de
inversión
de cambio de la manera de intercambiar
etcétera precisamente después de
reunirse con gustavo petro ha dicho que
se lleva muchos aprendizajes y sobre
todo piensa que gustavo petro es el
líder latinoamericano de izquierda más
avanzado